foreign
[Music]
optimizations for Java applications
and my name is oops wrong way
Aaron one Jolla and I am the Java
developer Advocate at Google Cloud
prior to becoming the advocate here for
the Java Advocate I was you know a
regular Java developer
and when I was on a team in an org in a
Sprint it never really made sense for me
to take time to look at what was
happening with different jdk vendors or
Frameworks as far as performance
optimizations to hold that in mind
because the problems didn't come up that
often
and that led to me not having them on
hand when I needed to apply them to a
slow project or a workload or web
service
and so the idea of this talk is that I
now that I'm a Advocate have the time to
sit back and keep up with where these
different optimizations are on their
release strains with different
Frameworks and in terms of their
Readiness and usefulness and prepare
that information for you in an easy kind
of practitioner level
bite-sized package so that you don't
have to do the legwork and you can just
have it in mind when your problems arise
so
to get started on this topic we're going
to start with the word optimizations
I got the wrong way it's a broad term
you can kind of land a plane on the word
optimizations hence the iceberg there
but I just want to talk about what I
mean in this context by optimization
and what we'll be focusing on today
um because there's a significant
difference in how I would approach
optimizing a slow call within an app
versus a slow app that's starting up in
general
versus an app that's building slowly and
so
um in my experience there's always
there's there's kind of three broad
classes of optimizations that are worth
um keeping in mind when you're going to
approach how to address them and so I I
say I would say that there's a build
time optimization where you are you have
the app code together you're looking to
ship an image or a jar
um that's one class of of slowness
another class is run time when the app
is up and running it may have been
running for a long time it may have run
the same operation tens of thousands of
times and this is where things like
jbm optimizations can come in and offer
performance boosts and then there are
start time optimizations which are
closely related to The Hot Topic of cold
starts where you may be in a serverless
context you may need a container to
start up very quickly and perform within
a certain amount of time when a customer
is waiting on the other end
and I would say that within those
different problem sets there are
different optimizations that should come
to mind and
approach the problems differently so I
think they're useful categories
I should also say that the format of the
talk is going to be
me going over a few of my thoughts about
this type of work and then I invite you
to come up afterwards there's gonna be
plenty of time for Q a there's a
microphone in the middle and if you see
value in this kind of Preparatory work
please let me know if you have any
questions about these optimizations
um I'm happy to answer them or get back
to you on them
another tool that I use to sort of
assess how I would
approach fixing a slow workload
is with this sort of flowchart so at the
top we have a slow workload that I'm
being presented with and I ask myself
you know when is the app slow is it in
the build time category start time
category or runtime
if it's in the build time category then
my first
approach is to
ask myself within the org like say I'm
working at a bank are our dependencies
changing very often or are we tied to
certain verified artifacts that we're
pulling the same way every time if so
there's an opportunity there to not have
to pull and build the same layers of the
same containers over and over again with
tools like
with tools that offer layered builds
which we'll get into in a minute
um if on the other hand there is a run
time in efficiency where
there's a hot path in the app and it's
just kind of algorithmically slow that's
more ambiguous class of problem to work
with
my first stop is always tracing
and then you kind of have to apply a
case-by-case optimizations
that is a topic all in its own that
deserves its own talk there's a lot to
be done with tools like cloudtrace to
offer performance games
but the bulk of the time we'll be
spending here is in the start time
optimizations
so a helpful question that I like to ask
with the new and emerging optimizations
is is this a long-running workload
I feel like that helps me pick between
different optimizations
because if it is a long running workload
or if it is not a long-runner workload
then an optimization like native image
compilation may be a good fit it's great
for optimizing short workloads there's a
set of trade-offs involved which I have
spoken and written about quite a bit
especially last year
um I can share my my blog posts on that
but if you do have a long running
workload and you want something like the
optimizations that the jvm can have for
running over a long period of time
and running the same operation over and
over again that you may not want to
adopt the closed World conception and
throw out the gvm with Native image
compilation instead you may want to take
an approach one of two approaches
based on another question which is are
you running many instances of the
workload
if you are then you may be leaning more
to class data sharing and if you aren't
then crack maybe a good option as well
now for myself a lot of these terms were
a lot of these projects were not top of
mind when I was working as a developer
most of the time because they just
didn't come up that often but I'm going
to take you through my journey of
familiarizing myself with these trying
them out seeing the situations where
they offer good performance gains and
where they offer fewer performance gains
and hopefully that will get you thinking
on how it could align your projects
so we're going to start with the build
time optimizations
one alternate one option for a low
effort but high yield build time
optimization is using a build tool that
we published in 2018 called jib
it's an alternative that is demon-less
produces fast reproducible builds and
does not need an installation to get
started you can actually just run it
from a maven coordinate if you don't
want to change your Project's Palm
so
um it's open source project and
in order to well there are there are
lots of people talking about it in the
community and how it is
an option on par with
um containerization methods like spring
boots built-in build pack support
there's a wonderful article attached to
that it's available in the slides from
the spring team
their are also significant performance
gains in the layered versus non-layered
image concept that I touched on earlier
so in the top left there you can see the
non-layered
taking an Uber jar and putting it into a
Docker file approach simple it works but
you will be building that entire app the
entire container from scratch each time
you change anything if you change a
single piece of app a single line of app
code you're re-pushing the entire
container with the entire jar rebundled
and as you can see that in the bottom
left it is in one big layer of 321
megabytes
whereas if you take a layered build
approach with the jib coordinate there
shown in the top right
instead jib automatically dices up your
app in a dependency layer
an app layer and
a libraries error layer
I believe and so that means that when
you change your app code only the
thinnest slice which is actually your
app code is being rebuilt and pushed
which if you apply it to a build server
running hundreds of builds for an entire
engineering or engineering organization
your savings are your time spent on each
cache layer times the number of builds
which can add up quickly
especially if you're paying for that
compute
um
so there's an overview on
jib is an option for layered building
next we'll be moving on to crack
which is
coordinated
restore at checkpoint
this is an emerging openjdk project
being developed by Azul that defines an
API for making use of your apps referral
to allow your apps to make use of
taking a running instance creating a
checkpoint and restoring the same app in
the same state from that checkpoint so
in a nutshell it is restoring a Java app
from a warmed up image and the words
warmed up are very important there
the performance results are compelling
from crack Zone Publications
these are if you're familiar with them
uh
results on par with Native image
compilation or neuron neuron par
with a different set of trade-offs so
a good option to keep in mind
um
now
there are some considerations involved
it is still in a pre-general
availability state it is getting
excellent support from Frameworks but it
involves certain kind of early adopter
steps like using a specific Tomcat
version that supports the coordinated
restarts of a running image or a running
application
um which is a hurdle
but the experience of using it is
actually relatively straightforward
you're able to run your uh run your Java
app normally with a flag to say
this is where I want to say that that
crack checkpoint 2 flag
defining a path where you'll be saving
your
um your checkpoint file
if you don't Define that I believe it
stores at Java home by default
and
then you run use the jcmd command to
restore from that checkpoint later with
the crack restore from CR command
and so I'd say International limitations
of crack are that it is still very new
very promising but very new it has
improving with limited support
um currently it only runs I've only been
able to get it to run on specific Linux
distributions not on Mac not on Windows
which
is likely not a problem for build or
deployment servers but likely an issue
for developer machines
and then the third is of course the
elephant in the room the dealing with
the snapshot
and I'd like to take a minute to talk
about that because
from the jdk perspective the snapshot is
being the snapshot handling is being
exposed as an API and Frameworks are
picking up that functionality at an
impressive rate so soon soon enough and
spring boot 3.1 which uses spring
framework 6.1 you'll be able to have
spring life cycle hooks that can feed
off of these snapshots and allow you to
tell your app what to do when warming up
from the one starting off from a warmed
up image so
these things are coming soon important
to keep in mind
um
now
and that's I would like to I'd like to
underline that
um crack is a good option if you are not
running several applications so as
opposed to class data sharing which
benefits from
being applied to several running
instances
of the same app
so class data sharing is a feature where
a feature that has been around in the
language for a long time
um
one of the many things I love about Java
is the Java enhancement proposal process
which provides like a great historical
record for the language its features and
their improvements over time
and because of that we can see
that class data sharing as a baseline
feature was established in 2004. in jdk
5.
so concept is fairly old but essentially
you are taking an allowed set of classes
and pre-processing it into a shared
archive
that can then be loaded into memory at
runtime to reduce the startup time of
other apps that use that shared archive
and of course that can also reduce the
memory footprint because many apps can
refer to the same class files with one
shared archive many jvms can refer to
the same class files so that reduces
memory runtime
and
a walkthrough of the experience using
Baseline CDs is pretty straightforward
you use the share flag and you have four
options dump creates the archive off
says do not use CDs on says use CDs
and fail if you don't like do not start
if you can't use the archive Auto means
use the archive if and only if it is
present in the place you expect it to be
so interesting straightforward pretty
simple a few years down the line we get
application application class data
sharing
in Jep 310.
and so this is where the application
class data sharing implementers came in
and said
what if we extend CDs to allow other
loaders rather than the built-in system
class loader to do the same sharing
trick to save memory at runtime and to
be more performant
this means that
it's so it could amplify the benefits of
the same class data sharing system
now it added another step to using the
class data sharing feature so you had to
use use app CDs to enable the feature
and then you had you this is a helper
function the listing it allows you to
list the files that it would be loading
at runtime to help direct you when
you're trying to create your archive and
make sure that you're dumping the
expected list of files and then pick
them up as expected later
and then finally the using step is when
you actually use the shared archive and
get the performance bonuses that are
promised
fantastic
but as you can see it's
um
it the performance benefits are
significant in the Jep they quote
reduction start time Productions of 30
to 20 to 30 percent in some swing use
cases
um but we'll get to my findings in a
minute here when I try to myself
in Jep 341 though
which was not that far apart and from
2017 to 2018
there was default app CVS became a goal
and so the idea with this Improvement
was to improve the out of the box
startup time for developers without
having them have to take on the hassle
of having to run extra dump and
deliberately take all these other steps
hence making it the default
so I found this to be very promising uh
even though as a first cut it only
targeted a subset of builds it was only
native 64-bit builds
but it's a step in the right direction
and
very promising for what comes next which
is dynamic CDs archives in 2018. again a
lot of movement in the last couple years
with these last two improvements
and so the goal here is to dynamically
detect which classes are loaded out of a
jar and which ones aren't so that you're
only loading the shared archive files
that would that would actually be used
between runs and making the whole class
data sharing feature transparent and
usable out of the box without
needing a whole bunch of steps and flags
for you to take on
or fewer at least and so this is the
part where I would normally tell you
like we're in the promised land and this
is uh fantastically easy and usable but
it wasn't immediately clear to me
how to get the benefits because when I
tried it
I ended up getting Vanishing returns or
in some cases negative returns
and that was despite the fact that I was
able to prove that it was using the
loaded files
but the issue was that
um I was really only running a single
instance of a single application where I
wasn't running enough instances of the
same application and so this is where
The Shining example of this is an app an
application where you can put up
multiple instances and have many many
jvms benefit from the same shared
archive files because otherwise it is
really just having one jvm pick up and
put down the same shared archive files
not much of a performance benefit so I
would keep that in mind
and then finally there's native image
compilation
so
native image compilation for those who
are not familiar
is
engaging in a trade-off
where you adopt ahead of time
compilation and instead of taking the
classic Java
use case of writing your application
once and running it everywhere where you
write the Java code and it runs on a jvm
on top of any architecture instead you
target a specific architecture at
compile time and go directly down to
bytecode to a native executable
sorry not by code
um so you that means that you target a
specific machine
with a specific architecture but you get
near native performance
as a result
it involves a number of trade-offs which
will be going off going into in a minute
and of course the the
most prominent way to engage in this
trade-off is with growlvm which is a
high performance jdk developed by Oracle
and in recent news it's gotten a
fantastic uptake from Frameworks like
quercus and spring and that's why I
think it's important for developers on
Google Cloud to keep in mind because it
is no longer a hard to use
um
kind of Arcane optimization it is being
put in your hands by fantastic work in
the spring in the open source community
so
this
all kind of came into General
availability last year with spring
framework three spring framework six and
spring boot three
and the benefits as I would State them
are smaller artifacts
you get faster startup times because you
are no longer shipping with a full
running jvm You're simply shipping the
resulting native code
and finally you have a smaller memory
footprint because you're not shifting
the jvm now there are a number of well
let me link over the benefits more
um
their
are significant reductions in startup
time and memory footprint
the graph on the right is from a blog
post that I wrote last year where in an
average of 250 startup times the native
image compilation started up in 0.6 of a
millisecond versus 132 for the same app
in
honor jvm
and the time to First request had a
similarly effective result so rather
than just starting up and being
technically available that was a spring
boot container that was ready to serve
requests at the end
um
and that was on an E2 standard machine
which is roughly equivalent to a 16 gig
MacBook
but there are a number of limitations to
keep in mind which are chiefly the
closed World conception meaning that you
have to accept that your app is taking a
snapshot of what is available on the
class path when it compiles and saying
that aside from a few exceptions nothing
else is coming in you're not loading in
new uh classes you're not loading in the
resources from the file system it is
mostly a closable conception without
specific annotation to get around it
I know the significant loss is that you
are losing the hot spot optimizations so
the jvm is very good at optimizing
long-running workloads as many of you
know
and so by giving up that jvm
it is best it is it is advised that you
do this in use cases where you know that
this is not going to be running for a
long time
um in some cases you may know that it's
going to run for shorter than a single
garbage collection cycle and you can
select a garbage collector that either
doesn't run or make sure that it works
well with how your workload is going to
encounter garbage collection Cycles
and the last trade-off is that your
build times are much longer because
they're much longer and they require
much more resources because you're doing
a lot more computation
at build time
the interpretation step of taking your
Java byte code to the native
instructions for the machine is running
on are an expensive step and that's what
accounts for the difference between Java
performance and native language
performance and so you're taking on all
of that cost right at the start for a
much more performant native executable
at runtime thank you